sequels have become such staples in
Hollywood that almost any film will get
one if the original makes enough money
with some movies however a franchise
hopes are so high in advance that a
follow-up is already being put in motion
long before the flick even hits theaters
which makes a fool that much harder if
and when it flops
here are some sequels that never
happened because their predecessor pics
were so poor
Independence Day 3 it took 20 years for
Independence Day to get its first sequel
but Independence Day resurgence was
expected to be the first of three
planned to follow-up films that would
continue Roland Emmerich's alien
invasion story the original movie was a
box-office smash and earned mostly
favorable reviews but resurgence turned
out to be too little too late to
resurrect that moment the movie was
slammed by critics for being in a lab
rat but ultimately empty spectacle and
while it wasn't an intergalactic bomb at
the ticket booth its lackluster receipts
didn't indicate much audience interest
in the movie or as potential sequels
either eventually those ambitious
franchise plans are seem to fizzle in
the wake of its release maybe they
shouldn't have killed off captain
Hillier after all there's still some
hope for those who'd like to see the
future of the series which would see
some of its heroes on a new space
adventure according to Emmerich he in
the studio are considering turning to
the small screen to carry out the next
Independence Day adventure who knows
maybe those crazy aliens will find the
welcome new home on the small screen
battleship 2 hopes were very high for
battleship so high in fact that
Universal Pictures signed a six-year
deal with Hasbro games makers of family
favorites like clue and Candyland so
that they could become the de-facto
board game to cinema provider however
its first big attempt was a 220 million
dollar wash for the studio as battleship
decidedly sunk with critics and
audiences alike director Peter Berg
place the blame on stiff competition in
particular Marvel's The Avengers but the
fact that it was derided for drowning
all plot potential in a sea of formulaic
action sequences didn't convince
audiences to hop aboard the ride either
battleship was set up to be a studio
tentpole but after it was torpedoed with
bad reviews and the dismal ticket sales
Universal quietly scuppered those plans
and several other Hasbro based picks
have been banking on a failed to set
sail as well maybe someone should have
foreseen that a boat movie by a guy
named Berg might not work out so well
divergent ascendant even the Veronica
Roth faithful were turned off by the
third installment of the divergent book
series the trilogy's finale received
grimmer reviews that his predecessors
from readers who were disappointed at
its hectic conclusion
so when Lionsgate announced to be
dividing the final adaptation
installment into two films the
collective eye rolling among divergent
fans was intense the first two divergent
installments weren't built for critics
so it didn't matter that they weren't
lapped with praise or prestige they
still earned enough money to justify
carrying on with the franchise however
the third film was an unmitigated
disaster on all fronts earning
laughingstock status with critics and
barely bringing in half of what
insurgent did at the box office the
production budget on the would be final
installment ascendant was immediately
slashed and that was just a start of its
trouble
the director soon diverged from the
project and after the studio revealed
they'll turn to television to produce a
final chapter several cast members
hopped off the train as well whether
it's dystopia fatigue or simple dislike
of the source material that caused
audiences to tune out the franchise
seemed to be lost before it could arrive
at his final destination several months
after its originally slated release date
for ascendant passed by however
Lionsgate announced a new plan to
develop divergent final leg as a TV
series on the Starz Network but without
its original initiate some bored to
finish the futuristic saga it hardly
qualifies as a true sequel jumper -
based on the Stephen Gould novels jumper
was a sci-fi extravaganza that was
clearly supposed to do more with a
promising young cast an open ending and
a frenetic story that could easily be
continued in new adventures it had
franchise hopeful written all over it
despite the tepid box-office taken
terrible reviews lead actor Hayden
Christensen claimed the sequel plans
were still in development with the
studio even two years after the
originals release according to him the
sequel would have followed his heroes to
a darker place leap forward a decade
though and 20th Century Fox is
officially out of the jumper movie
business director Doug Liman has since
managed to transport the property to
another locale for a reboot / sequel
produced by YouTube red however instead
of continuing on with Christensen's
characters journey based on the second
book reflex the new series will be
adapted from the third novel than the
series
Impulse this installment focuses on his
eventual daughter instead of him
meanwhile actor Jamie Bell has taken it
upon himself to start up another small
screen reboot - based on the property
which may or may not feature him in his
original role from the 2008 film did you
think you were the only one so well
jumper might have built a launch pad for
separate projects whatever launch plans
they had for jumper 2 have obviously
failed to clear the hurdle the power of
six the Pittacus lore novel series upon
which I am Number Four was based was
wildly popular when the first film
dropped and in an era when young adult
adaptations were all the rage and actor
Alex Pettyfer was considered the
up-and-coming heartthrob the film was
expected to launch a full-on franchise
for DreamWorks the sci-fi adventure told
the story of powerful alien teens who
are being hunted into extinction and
would have been followed up with Teresa
Palmer leading the power of six but
after the first film drew the ire of
critics and the disinterest of audiences
the sequel was ultimately shelved
screenwriter Marti Noxon told Collider
that result was regrettable because
number 6 was really awesome and they
would have liked to have seen a lot more
of her
we need another kick-ass girl heroine
considering how underwhelming four
turned out to be maybe they should have
just skipped ahead to the next number in
the first place
showgirls - Givens showgirls status as
one of the most widely derided movies of
all time it may be hard to believe that
could have ever been a sequel according
to director Paul Verhoeven however
elizabeth berkley was supposed to take
another turn on the stripper pole before
the movie's terrible reception left her
career in tatters he told a movie site
to Joe Blow we had already been working
on the sequel to showgirls which was
going to be called bimbos and was going
to beat no media's Hollywood but after
showgirls was released there was no way
anyone was going to give me the money
for that if we could just make a little
both Berkeley 20 years younger now I
would love to make bimbos today
considering how she seemed to
time-travel right back to high school
for that many Saved by the Bell reunion
in 2015 it's probably not a age that'll
keep them bows from ever happening
thanks for watching take the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to him
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]